MALE SPEAKER: Welcome to another
Android Developer Lab.
So thanks for joining us.
We are running three
minutes late.
But that's OK.
Hopefully that's given you
enough time to join.
So with that being said, let's
get started with the news.
The first bit of news
is really exciting.
And we're really proud of it.
The Nexus 7 tablet has won
gadget and tablet of the year.
So that's really awesome,
really fantastic.
We couldn't be prouder of the
Android engineering team, as
well as our partners ASUS.
And other than being a great
tablet for consumers to use,
it's a fantastic development
tablet, too.
So yeah, we're really,
really happy.
All right, moving onto more
developer-specific news.
We launched our trials
for subscriptions.
So now you get a period
where you can try the
subscription app--
not just magazines,
but even apps.
You can trial it for a little
while before the user has to
commit to purchasing it.
So this is a great way for users
to get a taste of the
app before they purchase it.
And we think it's going to
be really beneficial for
developers.
The next thing is that this
week has been tablet week.
Well, we said it
was last week.
And we certainly started
off with it, and our
European team as well.
We published some materials
this week.
So first was the blog, the
Android developers' blog.
And we talked about building
quality tablet apps.
It also had a link to our
developer portal called
Building Quality Apps.
And so on that Building Quality
Apps, there's actually
three sections.
And one of them specializes
on tablets.
It has a checklist to say, well,
this is what makes a
quality tablet app.
So for those of you that are
building phone apps and not
building tablet apps, now is
the best time to get in.
Last week's a ADL+ covered
fragments, which are really a
fundamental piece of building
apps for phones and tablets.
So if you haven't seen it
already, you should definitely
view last week's ADL+ app, and
then go along with this new
checklist that we've
published.
Next slide, please.
And over to you Anirudh.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Hi guys.
So for today's talk, we are
going to cover Connectivity
APIs, for Jelly Bean.
And we're going to announce
something really exciting at
the end of the presentation,
unconnected with the API, so
stay tuned.
So what we're going to look at
is, what are connectivity
APIs, and what's new
with Jelly Bean.
So basically, these are a set
of wireless APIs, and they
enable devices to communicate
between each other.
So they can communicate
with the cloud.
And that's about using your
regular Wi-Fi to connect to
your service on the cloud
and pull data.
And they can also talk
to each other.
So some of these technologies
that can enable this kind of
communication on Wi-Fi,
Bluetooth, and Android Beam,
which is built on
top of of NFC.
And these have existed
since ICS.
We had Android Beam.
And then Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
have done that much before.
So in terms of what's new for
Jelly Bean, we introduced
something called Wi-Fi Direct
Service Discovery and Network
Service Discovery.
And these are the two topics
we'll cover in detail.
With the launch of ICS, we
introduced Wi-Fi Direct, which
is a peer-to-peer technology
for connecting devices.
And with Jelly Bean, we've kind
of introduced Service
Discovery along with Wi-Fi.
So first look at
what Wi-Fi is.
Like I mentioned, it
allows peers--
which is devices within
their Wi-Fi range--
to find and discover
each other.
And once they discover each
other, they perform discovery.
They are able to connect and
then use sockets for
transferring data.
And it's kind of interesting,
because the Wi-Fi range is
much larger than the
Bluetooth range.
And also the connection
is high-speed
connection with Wi-Fi.
So it is a very interesting
and fast way of connecting
high-speed connections
between devices.
Which brings us to the new APIs
in Jelly Bean, which is
Wi-Fi Service Discovery.
So with regular Wi-Fi Direct,
which was introduced in ICS,
you could connect to devices.
And once you connect, you
first perform discovery.
And once a discovery is done,
you get the network details of
the other device, which is the
IP address to connect to.
And then you connect
to the device.
Once you connect to the device,
your application sort
of has to publish the services
available through the
application.
If your app is a game--
a Market Play game--
so only when the other device
was able to connect to you,
you can say hey, I have
multiplayer lobby available.
And this is how you start
exchanging data with me.
So this was actually a very
good user experience, that
you'd have to connect to devices
to figure out what
services are available.
So that's where the Wi-Fi
Service Discovery comes in--
Wi-Fi Direct Services
Discovery.
And it's a pre-association
discovery.
So you can actually find
services before establishing
or associating yourself to the
AP, which is the access point.
So you can figure out what
services are available.
And if you're interested, you
can connect to a particular
device which is hosting that
service, or the app that is
hosting that service
on the device.
So the devices--
and this comes from
Wi-Fi direct--
the devices are not connected to
a network, or don't have to
be connected to a network.
You do not have to have an
existing Wi-Fi network
around-- a classic router-based
access point around.
The devices can just connect to
each other whenever they're
near the Wi-Fi range
of each other.
Which basically means, before
they're assigned an IP address
on the network, they are able
to discover each other.
They discover the services and
the device itself, and then if
interested in the service,
establish a connection.
So this actually leads to
a really improved user
experience.
So you browse printing services
find transfer
services that are available
nearby.
And then you connect to a
device that you want to.
OK, some of the key APIs
for Wi-Fi P2P are--
sorry, we've got a video
feed from someone--
let me see.
MALE SPEAKER: Are we getting
some echo, Anirudh?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: So some of the
key APIs available as part of
the Wi-Fi P2P Service
Discovery APIs are--
and these are the
objects listed--
there's a Wi-Fi P2P service
info which encapsulates a
Wi-Fi P2P service.
And P2P here stands
for peer-to-peer,
which is Wi-Fi direct.
So there's a Wi-Fi direct
service involved which
encapsulates a service which
you want to publish.
Then there's a service
request.
And then there are two
specializations of these,
service request and
service info.
One is a DNS SD--
this is DNS-based service
discovery.
And the other one is UPnP, and
that is a popular Universal
Plug-and-Play protocol that
you find in a lot of media
devices and peer and their
compliant devices.
And this is specialized for
media technologies like
rendering and publishing streams
of audio and video.
So there's a specialization
for DNS space service, and
UPnP-based service.
So now we're going to get a bit
more technical and take a
look at coding and some code
snippets to see how does this
actually work.
So the first thing you want to
do from device A, which is the
first device that's interested
in connecting, or is
interested in being part of a
peer-to-peer exchange, will
publish a service.
So before you can actually
connect to a service, you need
to publish a service.
So you create a local
service object.
And what you do is you
have an instance name
and a service type.
So the instance name is
something that your
application is.
So this could be test, or
myChat or myPnPService.
And then there is a service
type, which is a standard name
that's followed.
And this list of names are
registered with IANA, which is
body that manages the
service types.
And so if you're publishing a
service that's not already
included as part of the IANA
services, you can register
your service type with
the IANA body then
use a service type.
So this would typically be
something, for example, for
chat service, we use something
called presence.
And presence is the name for
chat service so your service
type will be presence.
And similarly, there are names
for printing and for other
network services.
So what we've seen is, you're
able to create a
local service object.
And then you register this local
service with the Wi-Fi
P2P manager.
Wi-Fi P2P manager is a system
utility that's a frame of
class that's available to you,
just like the connectivity
manager or the telephony
manager.
You say
contacts.getSystemService and
then you say Wi-Fi P2P manager,
and you get a handle
to the manager object.
So we've seen the part of where
a device is able to
publish a service.
Now, on the peer device which
actually wants to use the
service or consume the service,
you will create a
service discovery request.
And then you will go ahead and
perform a service discovery.
So first you create an
associated object that
describes your request.
Basically you have some fields
that we will look into.
And then you ask the
Wi-Fi P2P manager
to perform the discovery.
So when you're implementing
this in Android, the first
thing is let's set some
of the permissions.
You need a change Wi-Fi state
and an access Wi-Fi state
permission.
Actually you need internet
It's not because we are
going to exchange
data off the internet.
It's only because we are going
to use sockets to communicate
between the devices.
And the sockets main
permission is
typed to sockets usage.
So you would require
this permission as
well in your manifest.
So now, at a code level, these
are the snippets of code.
And it's pretty easy
to write this code.
Just do three lines
per operation
that you want to perform.
So the first thing to
do to add as a peer
adding a local service.
So here's the service class that
we talked about earlier
as a key API.
This is Wi-Fi P2P DNS
service info.
And we just use a static
initializer on
that same new instance.
And the two things that you
are looking at, the
parameters, they are
the instance name
and the service type.
So the instance name is our
instance of a service, which
is _test here.
And because it's a kind of chat
m we are using a standard
name for the chat service.
And notice the naming
convention here.
This is followed for all the
services type for all
DNS-based services.
So it's underscore service type,
underscore the protocol
it's going to follow
on the network.
So the third thing is
really interesting.
It's record.
And this is a DNS
text recorder.
And this is also pretty much
standard, and this gathers
additional metadata about
your service.
So for example, if it's a chat
service, along with saying
that you have a chat service,
you also want to say that, as
a user, I am available to chat
at this point of time, or I am
busy and I cannot chat.
So the service is available,
but you are busy.
And you cannot respond
to chat messages.
So DNS TXTRECORD is
a key value thing.
And this is where you can
publish some additional
metadata about your service.
You can keep publishing these
records, which these records
can change over time.
So your service is published.
And it's available as
a chat service.
And then you can keep pushing
the DNS TXTRECORD, saying, I'm
available at this point
of time, I'm not
available, I'm busy.
So once you've done that, we
add the local service.
And the mManager object that
you'll see here is the Wi-Fi
P2P manager.
And then you add this
local service.
And there is a callback.
Many operations or almost all
operations of Wi-Fi P2P direct
and DNS network service
discovery are asynchronous.
And you always register
a callback
for success or failure.
So this is a standard
template for all
operations of service discovery.
So we instituted a service info
object, which had our
instance name and service type
on the DNS TXTRECORD.
And so once we've created that,
we go ahead and say
myManager.addLocalService.
And as soon as you do that, your
service is published over
the Wi-Fi network.
And in case there is an editor,
you can handle that
error and show appropriate
messages to the user.
So like I said, all the
operations are asynchronous.
So every time you perform an
operation, you're going to
pass a callback or register for
an action listener, like a
success/failure.
And because it's asynchronous
in nature, you don't have to
worry about where you're
placing this call.
It can be in your main thread.
The underlying network call is
always off the main thread.
So you don't have to worry about
writing asynchronous.
So it's in task and placing
these calls.
They're inherently
asynchronous.
So we've now published
a service with those
two lines of code.
So the other peer that's in
present been consuming where
your app is running, if it wants
to discover the nearby
service and connect to it, it
first needs to create a DNS as
the service response listener,
which basically is a callback
that has one method that says
onDnsSdServiceAvailable.
And we talked about UPnP.
And this is the same kind of
mechanism that we follow
around for UPnP.
So when there's a UPnP service
available, you would see
onPnpServiceAvailable
with a UPnP
service response listener.
So this is a callback-- the
method around the anonymous
implementation there is called
when the framework is
available to discover
a service.
When the Android device
discovers a service, it's
going to give you a
callback there.
So the first thing you do is
you initiate a service
response listener.
And you set it in
the managers.
So you say, Wi-Fi P2P
manager, here is my
service response listener.
In case there is a service,
call me back.
So we've set our response
listener.
And then what we want
to do is actually
create a service request.
This, once again, if
you remember, is
one of the key APIs.
So you will say, use the Wi-Fi
P2P service request object to
get a new instance--
again, a static initializer
there.
And once you're able to get a
service request, you add the
service request to the
Wi-Fi P2P manager.
And again, there's an
asynchronous callback
success/failure.
Once this is done, you actually
go ahead and perform
discovery by saying
mManager.discoverServices.
And then this is when the
firmware actually starts
discovering the services.
You've already registered
a response listener.
You've given your
service request.
And now the framework is able
to perform discovery.
And if it finds something, it's
able to callback on your
interfaces.
So once the DNS SD service is
available, you will also see
the Wi-Fi P2P device object
along with it.
This is basically a structure
that has details about the
peer IP and the other
connection details.
And this is when you can
actually go ahead and form a
network connection.
So you're able to query
the Wi-Fi P2P
manager for nearby services.
And suppose you find the service
of maybe a printing
service, or maybe a chat
service that you
want connect to.
At this point of time-- which is
after performing discovery,
and the thing that gives you a
callback on your interface--
you can now receive the
connection details and go
ahead and connect with
other device.
And this basically means
initiating an access point
association, and so once this
is done you're on the same
network now.
You get assigned IP addresses
on the same network, at the
same Wi-Fi P2P network.
And once this is done, you're
able to open sockets because
you're on the same
network now.
You can open TCP sockets and
start exchanging data, which
is your app data.
So what the framework is
really giving you is a
mechanism, it's sort of a
framework for discovering and
consuming other services.
So this was completely Wi-Fi
P2P, which is based on a Wi-Fi
peer-to-peer network.
So the condition there was,
there doesn't have to be an
existing network.
Two devices capable of Wi-Fi
P2P direct will find each
other, discover the
services, and go.
And the other thing is, the
other API that we just linked
with network service
discovery.
And this is basically based on
the fact that you're already
part of the network that
you want to join
and discover services.
So you're connected to
the network already.
In this network, you want to
discover services which are
available in your
local network.
So this is pretty similar to
Bonjour, if you've worked with
Bonjour on the Apple systems.
Or there are other Zeroconf
networking solutions available
on DNS and other platforms.
And this is basically bringing
the same Multicast DNS-based
service discovery to Android.
And we call it network
service discovery.
And like I mentioned, it's
different from Wi-Fi Direct,
because Wi-Fi Direct we didn't
really need the network.
And this is when you're
actually logged
in to a local network.
Suppose you bring your device
to your workplace and you
connect to your corporate
internet, and you have some
printers available and you
want to print maybe some
document, some PDF from
your mobile phone.
And many other printers
understand what is network
service discovery and
Multicast DNS.
So you can discover these
printing services available
and then go ahead and print
after you are able to make the
connection.
And again, file sharing is one
of the big things on the local
network, and multiplayer gaming
is really useful and
can really benefit from
technologies like Wi-Fi, P2P
Direct, and network
service discovery.
So we're going to technical
details of how it works.
In this case, you will
create something a
registration listener.
This is the device that's
publishing a service.
This may already be an existing
device on the
network, or it may be an
Android device which is
offering maybe a multiplayer
gaming
lobby, or a chat service.
And this is how to go ahead
and publish its service.
So you create something called
the registration listener.
And in terms of DNS-based
network service discovery, we
call it registration instead of
saying publishing a service
on the network.
So naming convention
is followed here.
So you register your service on
the network by creating a
callback for registration
listener.
And then you, again, have this
whole same kind of details.
You have the instance on
the service the type.
And the service type is
compliant with IANA.
And so here is some code.
Basically it's, again, a
callback on anonymous
implementation of registration
listener, which has some
standard methods, which is
your service has been
registered--
onServiceRegistered,
onRegistrationFailed,
onServiceUnregisered, and
onUnregistrationFailed.
So the framework is going to
call any of these methods,
depending on what really
happened with your request.
So you can listen to these
notifications and show the
proper URL go-ahead
with actually
connecting to devices.
So once you've created a
registration listener, what
you want to create is a
description for your service.
And again, we use something
called NSD service info.
The class is similar to those we
looked at earlier as Wi-Fi
P2P service info.
So the NSD service info here,
we set the service name, the
service type, and the network
port it's going to run on.
Because we are already in the
network, we can specify what
port my service will run on.
And you get a handle to NSD
manager, same as Wi-Fi P2P
Direct and other system
services.
You say Context.getSystemService
and
get a handle to NSD manager.
And once again the manager
handle, you create a
registration listener.
And you can say, register my
service, here is the info of
the service, and here is
registration listener, which
is the callback where the
framework will call you back
depending on what goes
on with your request.
So with this, now you've
registered your server.
So as you can see it's just two,
three lines of code per
operation, and it's pretty
easy to implement.
So now you've registered your
service on the network.
Or a DNS-based network NSD
service you've registered.
And now you want to discover
those services.
So what really happens behind
the scene is Multicast DNS
technologies involved here.
And you're listening to
a network broadcast.
And using some framework APIs,
you can filter out what
services you want to consume
or do not want to consume.
And again, it's asynchronous
API just
like Wi-Fi P2P Direct.
All the operations are performed
off the main thread.
So you could make your
call-in here.
So just like registration
listener, when you're
discovering services you
create something like
discovery listener.
And this will be used to
initiate service discovery.
Again, as you would have
guessed, it's a callback which
the framework is going to use
to call you back when it's
able to find something
for you.
So there is onDiscoveryStarted--
the framework has started
discovering services.
Again, time to update your
UR, tell the user
about locating service.
You're finding finding services
of OnServiceFound.
You get the callback with the
service info, what that
service is.
And this is where you can
perform [INAUDIBLE].
If you're not interested in
connecting to the service you
can reroute the service.
And there's some other callbacks
when the service is
lost, suppose the device goes
out of network or goes down.
You get the service lost.
Discovery is sort of
an ongoing process.
[INAUDIBLE].
So you can actually request
the framework to stop
discovering.
And that's when you get the
callback on discovery stop.
And some other callbacks, if
something failed, discovery
will stop discovery
fail, you get a
couple of other callbacks.
So now you've created a
discovery listener.
And what that means now is
to request discovery.
So you'd see an NSD manager
dot discover services.
Here is my discovery listener.
And you get the callbacks when
the framework has an update
for you, which is a table to
perform discovery and find
some service, or it failed.
It gives you a callback on
your discovery listener.
So all good, if the framework is
able to find your service.
And this is on the callback
onServiceFollow.
When it's able to do that, you
initiate something called a
resolve listener, which is to
find network details of the
peer so that you can connect.
So the resolve listener will
have callbacks again when the
framework is the able to resolve
the service for you,
which is to resolve
the IP for you.
And then you call the framework
once you create the
resolve listener and provide
them implementation, you call
NSD manager to resolve
service.
And that's it.
You get the IP details of the
device of the network machine
that's publishing the service.
And it's time for you
now to connect.
And the connection is basically
sockets, like we
discussed earlier.
You're on the network.
And if the service is
TCP-based, you get a
TCP-software or datagram.
So to summarize, we've looked at
two new key APIs, which we
like to call connectivity
APIs.
And these are Wi-Fi P2P service
discovery and Wi-Fi
Direct service discovery and
network service discovery.
So Wi-Fi P2P service discovery
protocol has a DNS and support
for UPnP implementation.
The thing about UPnP balance,
it's closely tied up with,
associated with the DLNA
protocol that's used between
many devices.
Your HD televisions, your
PlayStations, your Xboxes--
a lot of media--
DVD players, Blu-Ray players,
they're using DLNA protocol to
share and see media.
So one device is acting as
a streaming device that's
streaming the media.
The other acts as a renderer and
is able to show what the
other device is streaming.
And this is while working on top
of DLNA, UPnP protocols.
So Wi-Fi P2P service discovery
provides you the ability to
connect and publish
these services.
You could the media renderer
or you could share media.
And then there is network
service discovery, which is
sort of a Zeroconf networking
thing that's
sort similar to Bonjour.
And then you're able
to find DNS-based
services on the network.
And with this you can find
services when you're not
connected to the network using
Wi-Fi P2P Direct, and when you
are connected to
a network using
network service discovery.
So this brings us to the end
of the presentation here.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, Anirudh.
So Anirudh's obviously covered
a lot of things today about
all the options that you have
when it comes to connectivity
on Android.
And we think that the
capability is great.
And what we'd like to see is
more people use it and sort of
impress us to show us what are
the creative things you can
come up with.
So today I would like to
announce something new that
we're doing.
We're calling it a
ADL+ experiments.
And we're going to launch our
first experiment today.
So what ADL+ experiments is, is
it's a plus page that you
should go ahead and circle.
And this announcement that we're
just doing right now, we
will be making the same
announcement on the
plus page as well.
So ADL+ experiments is a way for
you to get involved with
the things that we present.
And today, we're launching our
first experiment, which is
based on the connectivity
APIs that Anirudh has
presented for us.
So the goal is very
simple, actually.
You're tasked with building
a cool app.
This is obviously optional for
you, whether you want to get
involved or not.
But we think this is a really
great way to showcase your
talents to the rest of the
developer community.
So build a cool app.
Come up with some great
concept using these
connectivity APIs, and then what
you should do is share
that APK with the plus
ADL experiments page.
So just send us a link to the
APK-- a download link, whether
it's Google Drive, or Dropbox,
or any other sort of service
that you may use.
And when you share with us, tell
us what the app is, and,
more importantly,
how to use it.
And tell us what makes
it special.
You can choose to share the
source code if you want,
whether you're using a GitHub
repository or otherwise,
Google code, for example.
And yeah, we'll take a look.
And this program in itself is
quite an experiment, where
we're launching it for
the first time.
So it's a way for you to
showcase your talents.
It's a way to sort of energize
the community.
And by all means, you
can collaborate.
So send us the submissions.
We put a cutoff date of
the 30th of October.
And feel free to send
the before then.
As we get submissions, we're
going to go through them.
And after that cutoff, the
incentive for you is we'll
pick a handful that we think
are really, really nice.
And we will highlight
these apps.
So it will drive some
downloads to you.
But more importantly, we'd like
to invite you to a future
ADL+, so you can tell us how
you built the app, what
challenges you had, and
have other people ask
questions as well.
So try and utilize these topics
that we're presenting.
And yeah, that's ADL+
experiments.
Anirudh, is there anything
you want to add to that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Just for this
specific topic, if you want to
learn more, there is an Android
training available
called Connecting Devices
Wirelessly.
And this can help you with your
first experiment, so go
ahead and take a look.
It's published on our Android
Developer site.
MALE SPEAKER: So hopefully this
means that people are
going to start submitting
apps, some work
that they're doing.
And these things don't need
to be complete apps.
They don't need to be published,
necessarily.
If they're published on
Play, that's great.
But these can be just tech
demos, effectively, where
you're showcasing something
cool that you're doing.
We love this developer
community.
And we're trying to see how
we can get you more
involved in the ADL+.
So ADL experiments--
we really hope you engage,
because it means that if you
find this sort of thing useful
then we'll do more of these
experiments in the future.
So we're going to talk about
this or mention ADL
experiments every week up
until that code cutoff.
And then in a future ADL+, we'll
try and showcase some of
these apps and see if
we can bring the
developers on as well.
So with that, we shall move on
to Q&A. We have one person
that's live on the Hangout
at the moment
who hasn't said anything.
But did you have any questions
to us before we shift to the
moderator page?
Doesn't look like it.
That's OK.
So we have a couple of questions
on moderator.
I'll read out the first one.
"I get errors from ICS users
with MapActivity.
An exception which is
basically a no class
definition exception found.
Android.security.MessageDigest.
If I Google the error, people
say that it's a problem
because an older version of
MapAPI is on the device.
How do I solve the problem?
The target SDK is version 16."
So I had a look at this.
And there's a handful of cases
where this has been reported
on Stack Overflow.
I wanted to ask you,
you said ICS users.
But on those Stack Overflow
threads, there were people
with Ice Cream Sandwich devices
that were saying hey,
this works fine for me.
I don't have problems
with this APK.
So I must admit, this
is an issue that I
haven't heard of before.
I'd love to get down to
the bottom of it.
So this is Mackan from Sweden.
And I apologize if I messed
up the pronunciation.
But please reach out
to me on Google+.
And let's see if we can
diagnose it further.
I'm interested in knowing
whether the devices that you
were testing on, is there
something special about them?
Are they normal Ice Cream
Sandwich devices that you buy
from a shop or from
your Telco?
Or are they running
custom ROMs?
Is there a chance that these
devices don't have the Google
services on them because they're
running a custom
version of the platform or
something along those lines?
And more importantly, are you
saying every single Ice Cream
Sandwich device is struggling
to run this APK?
So please reach out to me.
I'd love to follow up further.
Anirudh, did you want to
add anything to that?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: No, I think just
give us some more info
and we'll be able to help you.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we should
definitely try and get to the
bottom of this.
So next question.
"I'm new to Android development
and don't know how
to design and develop any app.
Could you please give me some
references from where I can
learn about the environment
setup and app development?
Thanks."
So this is Harshad from
Mumbai, India.
Look, the best place to start
is developer.android.com.
There's a section
called develop.
And there's a getting
started guide there.
It shows you how to download
the SDK, how to set it up.
And it even has some sample
apps that help you sort of
build the tutorials there.
So developer.android.com--
it's the place where you'll
find all of our tools.
It's where you'll find all
of our documentation.
If you have any sort of specific
questions, you should
definitely be posting
to Stack Overflow
using the Android tag.
And you'll have a huge
community of Android
developers that'll be just ready
and willing to help you.
The important thing is that your
question is very broad.
You're saying, hey look, I don't
know how to design or
develop any app.
It's really important to just
get your hands dirty.
Stop playing with the
tutorial, start
writing sample apps.
And in the beginning
it may be hard.
You may feel like, hey this is
not a very high quality app.
That's OK.
That's how you learn.
And that's really
the focus of it.
Next question.
"Can I retrieve data from the
Google Maps API so I can use
it for my location-based service
application that I'm
developing?" This is Prisy
from Philippines.
Anirudh, do you want
to take this one?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yes.
So the API that's available is
called Google Places API.
And that's what you would
probably like to use with your
location-based sources
available.
You can use this API.
It's a rest-based API.
And there is a token you need.
So what you need to do is go
to your developer console,
which is
code.google.com/api/console.
This is where you create a
project whenever you're trying
to use any of the APIs there.
So there, you need to enable
Google Places API.
And I think there is
some quota that's
available to you free.
And then you need
to pay beyond a
certain number of requests.
So if you're just trying
out, you could
probably try it for free.
And the Google Places
API is there.
And if you go to our
developer website,
developers.google.com, you can
look up the service reference,
and all the API reference,
and the different clients
available to you if
you do have a
Google Java client library.
And yes, you can pretty much
use the Places API.
And if I remember correctly, I
think Reto Meier, one of our
advocates-- you probably
know him--
he published a tutorial on
location-based services.
And he also shared the
sample source code.
So if you just look up the
history of the archives of
Android blog, you will probably
find this tutorial.
And he is using Places API
there to fetch places of
interest for another
location-based service,
basically allowing users to
check it when they want.
So go ahead and there's a lot
of samples of complete
applications that you
search in there.
So you'll find a lot of sample
code there on how to use
Google Places API.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool, thank you.
So the final question.
"Why can't the Google Play store
send back the install
referrers back either at the
Google Play developer console
or through an API?
Currently the in-device install
referrer process is broken.
We have big product marketing
plans around that feature."
And that's from Gopinath
in Bangalore, India.
Do you want to take this
one as well, Anirudh?
ANIRUDH DEWANI: Yeah.
So I don't really know if
it's not available.
And if it's not available, I
would say that this is a
feature request we can
take up to our team.
So just hang on to your big
product marketing plans before
it's released.
And I'm not even sure if it's
going to be released yet.
We will just take your feedback
to our product team
and see how they want
to prioritize this.
MALE SPEAKER: I was under the
impression that definitely we
do support referrers.
But I think the key thing here
might be that in the question
he mentions about the in-device
experience-- or
on-device I think is
what he meant--
that the referral process
might be broken.
Because if you do it by the
web, I'm pretty sure that
process works pretty well.
And I'd be surprised
if it didn't
translate well to the device.
Yeah, let us look that up for
you and run that past our team
and see if we get a response.
So please do reach out to either
Anirudh and myself.
And we're going to look
up the answer anyway.
But there's no way for us to
contact you directly here.
So yeah, we'll do that.
Just so you know, this question
I think is a fairly
new question.
It wasn't there a couple
of hours ago.
So we haven't had the
opportunity to have an answer
ready for this one.
I haven't seen any further
questions on moderator.
Are there any questions
on the thread where
we've hosted this?
Felix, could you just
check the--
we're just checking
the thread.
Nope, there doesn't
seem to be.
Well, thank you for
joining us.
We mentioned before that we
were announcing something.
And it was ADL experiments.
It's really for developers to
get their hands dirty with
this stuff.
So we hope that's
useful for you.
It's exciting for us, because
we get to see some of the
creativity the developers
come up with when
using these new APIs.
So thanks, Anirudh, for
presenting connectivity.
And thanks to all of
you for tuning in.
So that's us signing
off for this week.
We'll catch you next week.
ANIRUDH DEWANI: See you, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: See you later.